this morning there was finally a
response from the royal family
buckingham palace it's been silent ever
since prince harry and megan's high
stakes interview with oprah over the
weekend
royal observers call this the monarchy's
biggest crisis in decades
tina krause is in london
buckingham palace broke its silence
about prince harry and megan's explosive
royal revelations
in a statement palace officials said the
issues raised particularly that of race
are concerning
while some recollections may vary they
are taken very seriously
and will be addressed by the family
privately the monarchy is responding to
prince harry and megan's claims of
racism
after the couple told oprah someone in
the royal family was concerned what
color their baby's skin would be when it
was born
the whole royal family fall under
suspicion in terms of the race issue
but there's no doubt that's a very
serious allegation and something that
buckingham palace will want to take
extremely seriously
that control and the fear prince harry
and meghan's interview with oprah has
stirred up a backlash in britain
on the street i'm gonna pop up my
country
and i don't like that and on tv you
continue
to trash her okay i'm done with this
journalist piers morgan walked off the
set
during a heated debate about the royals
when they decided to talk to me i'll
stop
talking to the crowd megan's estranged
father thomas markle was quick to speak
with british tv
after watching the oprah interview from
his home in mexico
it went way over the top with
these stories with oprah can i ask what
did you think of the interview
earlier tuesday prince charles ignored
questions from reporters
while the palace often tries to stay out
of controversy by staying silent
royal watchers say this time they had no
choice
but to respond tina krauss cbs news